[музика]
коли почалася друга світова війна до
що
коли почалася друга світова війна
волинська різанина була коли почалася
друга світова війна
[музика]
41 його побув і обкидав і тим, що палять,
яйцям від нардепа закидав яйцями це
засмоктувала про те не вас силу і не що
такий сьогодні проживши миколаєве аллах
метою створення бойових загонів
тому що вони розуміють, що загибель це
не інші правоохоронні органи
[музика]
у авто 6 після такого прийому олег царів
написавши на своїй сторінці у фейсбуці
чорнив цибулю і дав позовами ним америці
nebula купа на виду у читку видно праву
фронтит на тему на прийом настя царева на
завершився столу та будинок ще прокуратура
за коли я йому посягаючи на територіально
вчилися з країни
[музика]
зовнішнє управління зовнішнього управління
зовнішнього управління ну вибач зараз
скажу я сподіваюся це моє персональне
думка те що україна унітарна країна
помилка
[музика]
ось це відео так добре ну прийшло з
вигляді будь ласка у вас член є ви
іноді член поправляєте але це
механічний рух
питання ви їх твій пройти поліграф
звичайно нічого собі ах поліграф готовий
пройти мене послухати вам не ви мені
говоритимете як каже українці і
росіяни один світ таке питання а ви
порадили б робити зі своїм іміджем
народному депутату про якого всі говорять
що він тупий
ще раз повторити поважалося для тіла
пройшли в політику для тіла ми зажадав
і вашу віру
вашу цю віру
для бурів біль
проти України та проти українського
народу
[музика]
ну
сьогодні вже зупиняється багато особисто
[оплески]
ялинка
зупиніться і нюхи намагаюся
територію нашої держави 3
безпечну для життя наших громадян
обидва сомів на кілок і хто нас поїдуть гості
тим більше
[музика]
для чука є свої власні переконання
я
вважаю, що він українські націоналісти
athlete на Батьківщині Володимир Путін
заїхавши до сну у кого медведчука паска не
глава адміністрації президента за
зустрічав путіни на розум взяти свою батьківщину
і на вітрилі свого розкішного особняка
на базі моря
у мені здалося а ціль справжній
залізничне перон стаття педаль не
[музика]
бруд не штучки
сказати дихаю вінки україни
ж і
сукіт ваш кує т.д. олігарх матвійчук
чистоту курчачись його срср
те, що всю кров
[оплески]
росія стрімко повертається в
голодні 90-ті роки забуте слово дефіцит
знову увійшло до лексикону за можливість
купити кілька кілограмів цукру люди
б'ються в буквальному значенні цього слова
щойно на спорожнілих полицях знову
з'являються упаковці із цукром покупці
змітають їх за лічені хвилини
[музика]
влада хоче щоб не було багатих ми
хочемо, щоб не було бідних жінок і
потрібні політики для того, щоб не дати
помаранчевий порушувати права жінок та
дітей
натомість в Україні не буде за референдум у
нас уже чотири з половиною мільйони
підписів я вам російською мовою говорю я
не дам з України робити ядерною
цвинтарі цього це не росія піднялася
ціна нас цього якщо не змогли
домовитися
юра не переживаємо і переміг я фартовий
влада собі за позиції неминуче
породжує ульт тривалості ось так і
працюємо працюємо для вас опозиційний
блок не так наш номер у виборчому
бюлетені 44
[музика]